[Musique]
bonsoir les petits amis heureusement
nicolas pour martin prenait lé bon soir
les neveux nounours bon le seul vite
gera tous les voir mais ne veut pas trop
allons-nous nous re ce ne soit pas un
tonton inquiet je ne suis pas inquiet
ils sont tellement sage c'est parce que
je les ai tout simplement
l'europe pom pom pom pom pom pom pom boy
alors c'est vrai qu'il a encore passé
qui te tout finit toujours pas nous
allons le trouver nous ton petit frère
bonsoir la grands fanions
ou mais je vois que mes neveux ont bonne
appétit et mon petit score d'un petit
oscar
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
pas preneur ou et au score
[Musique]
bonjour oui mon petit ange d'hossegor
ils courent toute la journée à quatre
pattes photo a derrière lui
[Musique]
c'est normal ça les bp
ça court toujours à cas pas seulement il
fallait le surveiller j'aurais voulu
d'ivoire toi de nous à fallon
cherchons oscar
oscar
mon chéri bien dire bonsoir à tonton
ce cas
je
viens dire bonsoir attentons tu parles
pas au score
toronto est la
coucou
le côté
oui tu
h 15 j'ai mis
quelques années
au score ou la table beaucoup
[Musique]
mangé
sous la table j'en suis sûr halo jaune
des voyous bientôt on va se fâche
voyons ce n'est plus l'heure de juin
un dodo et même du trajet à 6 heures
comme les bébés
comme ça on pourra s'amuser ensemble
bonne nuit les oursons
nous danserons si vous vous eh oui dany
boon hui tous mes enfants
là j'ai tanner
à 2
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai l'impression que ce petit ange
d'oscar donne bien du souci à notre
nounours je te comme lui quand j'étais
petit patron il me ressemble
il est si mignon allant en route
mon mignon nounours au
poteau bonne nuit des enfants faites de
beaux rêves
red bull
e
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
enfants
en
[Musique]